[Música]
las armas de fuego se cobraron otras
seis víctimas en Estados Unidos tres de
ellas menores de 9 años que perdieron la
vida en un tiroteo dentro de una escuela
de la ciudad de Nashville la presunta
autora que estaba Armada con dos rifles
de asalto y una pistola murió por
disparos de las autoridades
en Ecuador son siete los fallecidos y 46
los desaparecidos tras un deslizamiento
registrado en el sur del país las
Fuertes lluvias causaron el deslave que
deja más de 500 afectados al tiempo que
14 provincias están bajo estado de
emergencia
se cumple un año desde la declaración de
estado de excepción en El Salvador una
medida transitoria que se convirtió en
permanente y deja más de 66.000
detenidos según el gobierno una baja en
las cifras de inseguridad pero a un
elevado costo organizaciones denuncian
graves violaciones a los Derechos
Humanos
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos la ciudad de
Nashville es el escenario del último
episodio de una serie de tiroteos
mortales en escuelas de Estados Unidos
Audrey designada por la policía como una
persona trans de 28 años es la
sospechosa de asesinar a tres niños y a
tres integrantes del personal de una
escuela cristiana Por el momento no se
conoce el móvil del ataque tiene los
detalles
nueva escena de terror en Estados Unidos
Audrey hale de 28 años abrió fuego con
dos rifles de asalto y una pistola en la
joven en School una escuela cristiana de
Nashville y mató a tres niños y tres
miembros educativos la presunta atacante
fue abatida por la policía hemos
identificado la sospechosa es una mujer
de 28 años Blanca originaria de
Nashville o que vive en la zona
mis hallazgos iniciales es que en un
momento dado ella era un estudiante en
esa escuela pero no estoy seguro En qué
año
los tiroteos en centros escolares se han
convertido en algo alarmantemente
frecuentes en los últimos años en
Estados Unidos pero los llamamientos del
presidente para que el congreso
restablezca la prohibición Nacional de
los fusiles de asalto se han topado con
la oposición de los republicanos
Defensores acérrimos del derecho
constitucional aportar armas Es
simplemente enfermizo aún estamos
reuniendo las pruebas de lo que sucedió
Y por qué sucedió sabemos que hay un
número de personas que no van a
sobrevivir incluidos niños es
desgarrador la peor pesadilla
Así que pido al congreso de nuevo que
apruebe mi prohibición de armas de
asalto en lo que va del 2023 se
produjeron 129 tiroteos masivos
definidos Así cuando cuatro o más
personas fueron tiroteadas o asesinadas
según datos del
vamos a Cuba en donde la abstención en
la votación para elegir el nuevo
parlamento alcanzó
24,08%, una cifra superior a los
comicios de 2018 las elecciones tienen
como contexto una profunda crisis
económica desabastecimiento de alimentos
energía y un nuevo auge migratorio el
consejo electoral nacional Indicó que
del padrón electoral habilitado para
participar en las votaciones solo lo
hizo el
75,92%, lo que significa un 9% menos que
los comicios de 2018
cada vez son menos los que salen a votar
en Cuba el pasado domingo La Isla vivió
un proceso electoral sombrío cuando se
celebraban los comicios para elegir a
los miembros de la asamblea nacional
cubana Los altos niveles de abstención
ciudadana resaltaron en la jornada según
cifras oficiales la participación fue
del
68.58% del padrón electoral la más baja
desde 1976 además el 10% de las boletas
fueron anu al ser en su mayoría
papeletas en blanco el aumento en la
abstención de los cubanos es real sin
embargo desde el gobierno se desestima
el fenómeno Estoy seguro que va a ser
una excelente jornada que los candidatos
van a ser electos con un amplio apoyo y
que las elecciones cubanas van a seguir
siendo ejemplares y distintas los
índices de abstención se han elevado
desde el referendo constitucional del
2019 y el domingo llegaron a su pico
histórico el tradicional antagonista
para Cuba Estados Unidos ha reaccionado
al fenómeno el subsecretario del
departamento de estado para América
Latina criticó los comicios cubanos
cuando la única opción es el partido
comunista y comité cerrado se eligen
candidatos para postularse sin oposición
no hay democracia históricamente la
participación ciudadana en las
elecciones cubanas ha sido una de las
más altas del continente oscilando entre
el 80 y el 90% de la población saliendo
a emitir su voto sin embargo la crisis
económica y social que azota la isla ha
provocado que muchos cubanos demuestren
su malestar con la decisión de no salir
a votar pasamos a Ecuador donde las
Fuertes lluvias han provocado un
deslizamiento de tierra en el sur del
país las autoridades rectificaron que
siete personas y no 16 han fallecido al
tiempo que hay 46 desaparecidos y 500
afectados que han perdido sufrido daños
en sus viviendas el deslave fue causado
por las precipitaciones que mantienen a
14 provincias bajo estado de emergencia
Alba Santana tiene los detalles
tragedia en el sur de Ecuador tras las
intensas lluvias en la localidad de la
UCI un deslizamiento de tierra se saldó
con la vida de varias a personas dejando
algunas casas cubiertas de lodo y otras
totalmente destruidas
un tremendo sonido dije ya se desploma
el cerro El Fuerte temporal deja al
menos 500 damnificados y varios
desaparecidos que ahora los equipos de
rescate y los voluntarios se esfuerzan
por encontrar estamos parado aquí sobre
20 metros de material pétreo que cubre
un estadio aquí abajo entre la
desolación de los vecinos en la conocida
como nariz del [__] por su pronunciada
pendiente El Ejecutivo de lasso prometió
actuar para ayudar a Los afectados el
gobierno está totalmente activo enfocado
en la tragedia de
tanto la dirección de riesgos cuerpo de
bomberos fuerzas armadas policía la Cruz
Roja el Ministerio de salud pública y el
Ministerio de bienestar social más allá
de la UCI las Fuertes lluvias han
destruido carreteras puentes y otras
infraestructuras en todo el país solo en
lo que va de año se han reportado
987 incidentes peligrosos relacionados
con las precipitaciones por lo que el
gobierno declaró estado de emergencia en
14 provincias se cumplió un año desde
que el presidente nayib bukele ordenó un
régimen de excepción para enfrentar a
las temidas pandillas omaras
salvadoreñas durante esta medida que
suspendió algunas garantías
constitucionales de la población la tasa
de homicidios cayó considerablemente y
parece haber desarticulado a esas
estructuras criminales con más de 66.000
capturas realizadas sin embargo las
acciones de bukele también son
criticadas por el abuso de poder
el temido callejón de la muerte
aquí Noé recibió seis impactos de bala
de manos de La Pandilla barrio 18 en
entró con el régimen de excepción
impuesto hace un año por el presidente
nayib bukele los ciudadanos de este
suburbio de San Salvador hoy se siente
más seguros según las encuestas esta
medida es apoyada por un 80% de la
población con la seguridad y que el
apuesto y el régimen que hay estamos
felices
pero Osvaldo no está feliz su esposa
Claudia fue detenida hace 11 meses y su
caso se suma a las 5000 denuncias de
capturas injustificadas bajo este
régimen pero esa es la lucha por querer
demostrar ante el juez con los arraigos
pues la inocencia y la injusticia que
están cometiendo en el caso de ella pero
ante los medios de comunicación
nacionales
y ante los informes del gobierno ya ahí
aparece como una terrorista para la
fundación de estudios para la aplicación
del derecho la percepción de seguridad
en el régimen es un Espejismo tras el
que se oculta la institucionalización de
violaciones a derechos humanos es un
pretexto para reprimir no para combatir
la delincuencia
aquí haya una ausencia total de una
política criminal
el gobierno adjudica la reducción de
homicidios a la detención de más de
66.000 personas este último año pero las
madres que demandan la liberación de sus
hijos en las calles no están de acuerdo
con los procesos y
hay tiempo según cifras del gobierno la
medida ha sido un logro porque la tasa
de homicidios en 12 meses es 3,6 muertes
por cada cien mil habitantes mientras
que en 2015 era de 103 ahora la
excepción de garantía Es una constante y
la preocupación de las familias
salvadoreñas es que buenos y malos están
siendo detenidos sin distinción
finalizamos con una buena noticia porque
Ranger un Espécimen rescatado hace un
año y transportado en avión a los callos
de Florida está socializando con otros
delfines el macho huérfano fue rescatado
en 2021 en Texas en ese momento sufría
de una infección respiratoria y
deshidratación con Solo dos años se
Consideró que era Demasiado joven para
alimentarse y sobrevivir en la
naturaleza Ranger Ahora tiene unos tres
años y los responsables destacan sus
avances tras un arduo proceso
es todo por el momento en France 24
quédense con nosotros
[Música]